i think it's true in many things in life
if we wait for things to happen to us
uh some things may have i mean many
things will happen to you
however by being proactive by taking
initiatives uh by pursuing your goals
it's more likely that good things are
going to happen to you and certainly
i found in language learning that as
long as i was a passive learner in
school
with the teacher teaching me and as long
as i waited for the teacher somehow or
the textbook to teach me i wasn't making
very good progress once i took control
of my learning once i went out and and
this means looking for
things in the language that interest me
books
in the case of chinese books with in
those days before the the internet books
with
vocabulary lists behind each
chapter
taking the initiative initiative in
terms of what i want to learn about what
aspects of the language i need to work
on uh taking the initiative
not to stay with the program uh that the
teacher is is uh leading you
uh
into in the classroom
many teachers don't like this they don't
want the students to get ahead of them
this is so wrong because
the language
isn't just chapter one chapter two
chapter three the language is is
basically a whole
package and we learn
we learn different parts of it again and
again and again and so for the student
to go out and find things of interest to
him or her
and then go back and do what they're
doing in class all of this is good you
have to take the initiative you have to
take responsibility there are people who
say
that there's no bad learner there's only
a bad teacher i don't believe that at
all i think whether you are in a
classroom or whether you are studying on
your own
only those learners who take the
initiative who are motivated enough to
take charge of their learning are going
to be successful and
we have ample evidence of this in our
school system in canada and i'm sure in
other language schools where a small
percentage of the learners actually
improve
and
an equally large number can improve on
their own if they're motivated so that
the
important point is not the number of
instructional hours
the important point is to what extent
are you prepared to be proactive and
take charge of your own learning